we can see you and hear you we see you
and hear you
oh you can all good well in that case i
don't need to plug in
i'm here in hudson my wife is in the
other room
good morning representative russell ober
you're in hudson with the six cats
representative fred ducette good morning
uh home office in salem alone your
humble clerk is in beautiful nottingham
new hampshire
in my home office by myself
representative robert elliott
i'm here in salem new hampshire and my
wife is in the main dining room
representative john genigeon good
morning i'm here in salem and my wife is
in the house
representative herschel nunes good
morning mr clerk and colleagues i am
home alone in pelham new hampshire
good morning representative tim baxter
good morning mr clerk i am home alone
and thankfully i do
not have six cats representative walters
pillsbury
good morning i'm home in charlestown one
son in the house
representative paul tudor good morning
i'm
home alone in northwood out of the
cellar today representative susan
good morning on i'm in home alone in
lebanon looking at a piece of
beautiful forest very good
representative richard ames
yes i'm here in jeffrey in my home
office
alone thank you representative tom
southworth
here and over alone substituting for
dennis
malloy it's always a pleasure to have
i'm unmuted in durham alone
welcome the honorable representative
thomas c schaumburg
uh thank you mr clerk i am here in
wilmington my wife is upstairs in her
office
good morning sir representative edith
tucker
i'm home alone in randall representative
jenny gomarlo
aaron swansea alone representative tom
lochman
representative amanda gorg good morning
i am present and alone
representative mary hacken phillips
morning and present
and alone in my concord office
representative james murphy
good morning i am alone in my home
office in hanover
our chairman representative norman major
good morning i'm in my home
in my office in plasto and my wife is in
the house
mr chair there are 23 members present
one member is absent
this morning we're going to
be dealing with senate bill 3. we'll
start
by a work session and then if there's
no more new information then we will go
into executive session
well let me first say a couple words
we as a committee of members of the ways
and means
are here to evaluate each of the
proposed house and senate bills that
come before our committee
is the bill simple or complicated
what is the purpose and goal of the bill
there negative consequences of the bill
what are the positive benefits of the
bill
who will it hurt who will it benefit
through the positive benefits outweigh
the negative consequences
of a bill senate bill 3
has been a very complicated bill
to get to the answers to the questions
we've talked about to talk as a
committee
to many groups cpas and accountants
chambers of commerce from all over the
state
small and large businesses legislative
budget office
the department of revenue legislators
and national organizations such as
we heard on interpretation of the rules
of utilizing the american rescue plan
act
finals we sought and received
information on the negative and positive
benefits
in the bill 3 and hopefully we are now
ready to make a decision
for senate bill 3. does the positive
benefits
outweigh the negative benefits and
before we go into executive session
in the work session so if there's any
new information
let's have it and go through it
does any member have any new additional
information that they want to share
on senate bill three representative
susan elleny thank you mr chairman
uh i do not have it but you just sent
something
out that specifies that phase
one totaled 2.5 billion
which i think we've been considering as
for both phases
and that the total including phase
two to date which is almost complete is
to new hampshire on and
on i'm wondering on i think that
we need to pass this bill but unamended
but uh i think we also owe it
to the legislature
and the state to
give an idea of
how much money this is going to be in
total and
when when it could show up
uh in which years and on
i know you've been working on that we've
all been working on that
uh on but we have a fiscal note from dra
which i think was
essentially coming out at around 2.5
wasn't it i'd like to hear from dra
where they think we're going on that
knowing that the total is 3.7
when they have given us some timing
information already but
on whether that changes their fiscal
note
thing oh representative
you're right we didn't
did meet with the dra yesterday and
they're going to be meeting with the
committee
on tomorrow and
the information that was sent out devin
who was a member of the dre
updated the information on the number of
businesses in new hampshire
for the first stimulus package and the
second stimulus package
and this is what the numbers of
businesses today
have been that have received and you
come up with an average
amount that was sent out to the
committee members this morning
uh i didn't notice it in what you said
i'm sorry i only noticed
and so tomorrow we'll find out what
today
cost can we put it in the blurb sorry
report
um i'm gonna be writing a report it's
already in there
i i'll have it in there okay and it does
include the 3.7 million
yes billion and i just want to apologize
to everybody i sent the wrong
wrong report out yesterday uh and we did
get clarification from devon
and dra yesterday it's 41
173 businesses as of may
23rd uh and
approximately 3.7 billion correct
and that will be in the blurb or the
report
thank you it would be good if it could
also
include some kind of estimate of the
timing it looks like most of this
is going to come due next year and the
year after
we will have something on the timing the
and we should have that
finished tomorrow also
because that timing for everything
associated with ppp
representative brownlee followed by
representative ames
i know that's that's what i wanted to
say
okay uh thank you and um
i i too uh look forward to voting
this bill out unamended um
i think it's uh following from
federal policy on this program as a
stimulus bill
that has on the whole worked well
and i think for new hampshire to go off
in a different direction would be a bad
idea
so on that score i'll be uh
i look forward to going into executive
session on this i do want to say on
revenues
that um yes absolutely we need to look
at those and calculate those
as best we can but i emphasize as best
we can
because there's a great deal we do not
know about
uh the way in which the degree to which
taxes have been paid on forgiven or
anticipated forgiven ppp loans
and we'll talk more about that tomorrow
i look forward to that discussion
but i want to put a big question mark
atop the other figures that have been
mentioned about the ppp
loan program it's a lot of money that
has
flowed to the state as
originally as loans and that's for sure
we know that
we don't know what it's translated to in
anticipated uh
payments of business profits tax um
so that's my my thought thank you
thank you representatives anybody else
having
additional information and they want to
saying none then going to
representative margie smith
thank you mr chairman this question
might be
um might show that i'm
a trespasser here today and that i don't
know enough but
i am curious as to the path
that the federal funds take
when they come into the state
is
does this money follow the traditional
route that exists exist historically
or does it go um
through the governor rather
than through other um repositories
this is a p that has to do with the ppp
forth to a bank
and to my knowledge does not go to the
state it goes
as a result of the bank dealing with the
treasury
and the treasury sends the money to the
business thank you very much
for uh making that clear to me i
appreciate the chairman
if i could the sba is the contact in
between the banks
and the treasury that is correct small
business association
administration mr chairman i have a
question for uh representative
hold your question until i finish okay
the s as far as representative
hill and representative smith the sba is
the ones
that will give the approval has been
used for its intended purpose if they
get the loan
and they don't use it for
the purpose that can be forgiven and it
will not be forgiven it will be taxed
if they use it for wages enough things
to support that
then it will be forgiven so
the sba plays an important part of
can you hear me yes okay my question was
um i had the feds giving us
1.7 billion in ppp
loans uh representative almighty said
3.7 billion is is that the current
figure that the feds are giving to the
con
to new hampshire when you look at
at both the first
round and the second round it amounts to
the 3.7
mr chairman if i could on representative
elliott it was in the email that was
sent us this morning just before this
meeting
aha
if i could ask a question to the chair i
believe if the loan is not
forgiven it is still alone they have to
pay it back
and it is not taxable
that we don't tax loans that they're
paying back
that i'm not an accountant so i'm going
dra could and that's a good question to
but representative elliott that email
that was sent to
billion dollars for the second round
and 2.56 for the first round a total of
thank you mr jim representative
spillsberg
sorry for the mute uh yes representative
olney
uh a loan is not a taxable event
it's the forgiveness of the loan that
creates the taxable event
thank you that's what i was trying to
to get so we
we do have carol and lear in the
attendees and
it's great that we have such a broad
breath
of talent on this committee
one person doesn't know the answer and
we've got some expertise and
another person okay represent a health
thank you mr chairman uh do i understand
from
prior conversations that at this present
time we don't
know um how many businesses and how many
dollars
have been forgiven um and how many
remain as a loan that is correct
because you get the loan
and then you use it or wages and all
that
then you apply for the forgiveness and
that comes
further down the line and so we won
on this first section of loans which was
they won't hit the dra
this fall or even they might even be
thank you mr chairman quick follow-up
yes
um is it true
is there a timetable for when a business
owner
will know when
that loan is uh is forgiven or not
and and does that exceed the time
frame when um taxes need to be filed
that would be a good question for
tomorrow thank you
representative yes uh
our sense is that most of the loans will
be forgiven uh
we could talk to the dra they most of
the businesses
understand what they have to do to have
their loan forgiven and that's spend the
money appropriately
uh they had to spend there was there
were strings around that money
as to how it could be spent and i think
and
i think the dra could weigh in may
possibly right now about
uh their sense uh in the math that they
did to come up with the
the cost of 99.4 million dollars
uh that they've they figured a certain
percentage of the loans that would be
forgiven in that math
and i think it was a pretty high
percentage of almost all
maybe we can hear from them right now
can you um janine can you
let carol and
carolyn good morning mr
chair carolyn lear assistant
commissioner at the new hampshire
department of revenue
so if i understand representative hill's
question i think it has
two parts the first being that we have
presumed in our fiscal impact statement
that 100 of all ppp
loans will ultimately be forgiven
um although a
large percentage of ppp loans
have not been submitted for forgiveness
yet
for those um for those ones that have
been
submitted for forgiveness only a very
very small less than i think two or
three percent
have been denied forgiveness so i think
that's
likely a somewhat reasonable assumption
that we've made
there our timing analysis
does make some assumptions
about when those loans will ultimately
be forgiven
um i think at a very high level
um for the first issuance of ppp
loans we've assumed that those loans
have or will be forgiven um
in short order and then for the
second issuance we've assumed a bit more
of an extended period
for those loans to be forgiven
recipients can submit their application
for forgiveness as soon as they have
spent the money
and do they have a time limit on
submitting those applications
you know i don't know the answer to that
question representative
i think they have a natural time limit
as it relates to the repayment terms
they certainly want to get
it forgiven um quickly but i don't know
if they actually have a deadline i'm
sure they do i just don't have it handy
okay reps and all me
thank you mr chairman on the
the phase one had a deadline for
the sba to approve
forgiveness i believe of the end of last
year there was a major problem
in that the guidance was unclear enough
that
sba and the banks that were supposed to
submit the applications for the
applicants on could not
figure out how to do it well enough
and and sba how to
approve them and pass the money down
well enough
so if there was a considerable delay on
that and phase
one apparently now is on track
to to get through the rest of phase one
pretty quickly
and phase two didn't have i think had
pretty similar almost completely
identical
uh criteria so it should be going
faster but um all of these you have to
spend the money
beforehand and then you have to go to
the back to the bank
and ask them to fill out the correct
forms
so uh it it has been
a lot more delayed than the original
legislation said and they seem to have
thank you mr chairman so do i understand
that there will be
some form of carry forward
if if the approval
arrives after the time at which
a business that extends their
filing period uh it doesn't receive that
approval of their forgiveness
carolyn thank you for the question
representative so our analysis
assumes that the loan would um
would have been reported in income in
the year the forgiveness is
actually received um we talked quite
extensively
with the committee about the fact that
many
taxpayers will have reported the
expenses
in one year and the forgiveness
in a later year and that in that
scenario
the year when the expenses were reported
would likely
generate an nol that would be carried
forward to offset the income
in a later year
any other information
or questions that the committee members
have before we go into the executive
session
i don't see any races so we will go into
executive session
on senate bill 3 and i'll recognize
representative brunson
i move out to pass on senate bill three
senate bill uh three hit
representative romney made a motion one
second then
again second as well
all right i don't know i think
representative ames was
james yes representative ames exactly
he beat me to the punch hmm
let me just review emotions ought to
pass by representative bromley second by
representing ames
are there any further questions i'd like
to speak to my
motion please representative romney
thank you mr chair i just want to say
that we as a committee have
done much fact-finding and discussion on
this bill
representative spillsbury challenges
saul with with the introduction of his
amendment
which forced us to examine in greater
detail the ramifications of this bill
we all heard compelling testimony from
individual businesses and the various
chambers of commerce's
who support passage of senate bill 3.
the chamber did a great job in reminding
us all
what a crisis we were in last spring and
what a lifeline the ppp
program was to so many of our our
businesses
they reminded us that this program was a
relief program
for me this simply comes down to should
we be taxing relief money or not
i've concluded passage of sp3 is the
right thing to do
and that we should not tax relief money
from uh we heard from the from the dra
that passing sb3 will reduce
future tax revenues by 99.4 million
dollars given our business tax revenues
as of today are running 172.7 million
above budget and that's made up of
april april year to date 175.5 million
reduced to 18.3 through three
million of anomalous uh revenues from
last year
and then adding may as of today
may is running 16.5 million above budget
so we're continuing to have another good
a month of revenue so
we're that that equals 172.7 uh may
2050 at a date uh over it over
budget revenue for business taxes
with that there is no question in my
mind that the state
can afford to cover the the lost revenue
in future years due to
the passage of sb3 this can happen if
the 172.7 million is managed properly
which i am confident it will be
hopefully you will all join me
voting yes on sb3 as we do our part
in helping new hampshire businesses
rebound post
covet 19. thank you mr chair
thank you representative representative
ames
thank you um i i uh
not only seconded uh representative
ramy's motion but i second
uh what he has just said in support of
passage of sb3
unamended and i think the
uh to begin with i do want to say uh
a big thank you to our chair for
presiding over a very careful and
thorough
uh review of this spill and its
ramifications is a complicated
subject and uh we've certainly explored
it
and uh with the able help of
representative spillsbury who
who dove into this and raised questions
that
needed to be explored so thank you
to everyone i guess for
this endeavor which is a serious
appropriate
way for the legislative committee to
proceed on a
a difficult bill and i think
we're doing just the right thing we're
carrying through on a federal program
that was designed to respond to
the pandemic and its economic uh
its adverse economic effects both uh
both already felt at the time of passage
of the ppp
program uh or anticipated or feared
and um it's uh it's played out very well
for many of our businesses
and uh it needs to be immediately added
for many of those business employees who
were able to be kept on payroll
continue to get their health insurance
for example
as the as we made our way through the
pandemic and the ppp program made all
that possible
the federal government decided at the
outset that they would look at this as a
stimulus program as an investment
in the economy and not as a
program that would play out in any
particular way
in the profit and loss statements of
corporations or businesses
but rather as a broad stimulus and
for that reason they chose not to to
tax the loan program when it became a
forgiven
loan program for when forgiveness
entered into the picture
and i think that was exactly the right
choice
of 40 41 i'm not sure that your number
states have agreed and
and gone down the same pathway as the
federal government with
their local business taxes there are a
number of a few other states
uh above that 41 uh
number that simply don't have a business
tax so
it's really a most most states are on
board with this approach
i think it's good that new hampshire is
about to go down that road i hope it is
going to go down that road with the
support of the full house
so i look forward to voting on this bill
favorably to send it forward to the
house floor
thank you representative representative
thank you mr chairman on first i want to
echo representative ames thanks
for the work you and
all of us many uh have done
to examine the implications of this bill
and to underline that we need
to make it clear to the house and the
senate and the governor
on that that 99 million
number of cost is very approximate
and that it is very
pro and it is very likely that whatever
money that
is is within the surplus that we are
seeing
for the business taxes and needs
to be saved not spent because we're
going to have to pay it back
thank you thank you representative
representative spielsberg
thank you mr chairman um i very much
appreciate
the committee's patience and allowing me
to ask extensive questions
and make comments i appreciate the
collaboration i've seen across
the entire committee and the quality
and thoughtfulness of the entire
discussion i'm glad we gave it
the extra time uh it certainly deserved
that
so i think we've pieced everything out
and at the end of the day it's not a
mathematical equation
it's a value judgment so
we've gone through four revised fiscal
notes
we extensively debated an amendment
i had another one prepared along the
lines of virginia's limitation
and decided not to advance it
because i think at the end of the day
we've received more revenue than planned
we can afford to give some back and i
view this as a
further stimulus and effectively a
one-time discount
on the business profit tax rates so
um i appreciate all the responses i've
had to my questions
and i'm very comfortable to vote yes on
sb3
thank you representative spellsberg
spellsburg any further
comments or questions before we go to
saying none then i'll ask the clerk to
call the vote
uh senate bill 3 and the motion is
octopass
thank you mr chair let's begin the roll
call vote on sb3 with the motion of
octopass
with representative patrick abrami yes
representative greg hill yes
representative jordan owerry yes
representative russell ober yes
representative fred ducette yes
clerk votes yes representative robert
elliott
yes representative john genigean
yes representative herschel nunes
yes representative tim baxter
yes representative walter spillsbury
yes representative paul tudor
yes representative susan almi
yes representative richard ames
yes representative thomas southworth
yes representative marjorie smith
yes the honorable representative thomas
c
schamberg representative schamberg votes
yes
representative tucker yes
representative jenny gomarlo yes
uh representative tom loffman is still
representative amanda gorg uh yes
representative norman major yes
mr chair the vote is 23 yes
zero no votes the vote been 23
yes zero no votes the motion about to
pass on senate bill 3
passes well thank you very much
and we are now out of executive sessions
is the chair
do you think it's gonna be on the
consent calendar
no i don't think it can okay just just
double checking
definitely it's only a hundred million
dollars yeah let's do it on
consent we've done other things like
that
and then tomorrow we're going to be
meeting at 10 o'clock
with the dra to go over revenues
on the revenue projections that they
shared with the senate
uh which should be a very interesting
day
and then we can continue asking
questions relative to the ppp loans
any further questions or comments
represented southwest followed by
representative nunes uh thank you really
it's for the chair um the dra
charts have been very useful you know
the sb3 chart and the
impact of reducing the taxes um i'm
wondering if there's a plan down the
road
to put all that information on one page
you know right now you can add the
charts together
there also might be some new changes too
but would seem like our committee
will need going down the road one chart
with everything on it
we are we're working on that which shows
the reduction and the meals and loans
tax
and it goes out from 22 all the way to
30.
the reduction in the bet
rate reduction the bpt rate
the threshold going up on the b
pt the
elimination or the phase out of the
interest and dividend tax
and a few others along with the credit
carryover
and the ppp
thank you money and that'll show it all
that we're going out to
here 20 30 by year and that's
almost done and hopefully we'll have
uh representative nunes thank you mr
chairman and this doesn't really have to
do specifically with this bill but i
believe this is our last bill of this
session is that correct
this is the last bill yes
thank you mr chairman i i just want to
tell you and
everybody else on this committee this
session has gone very well for this
committee in my
eyes i'm only as a second term
representative
and i just want to tell everybody in
this committee how much i appreciate all
of their hard work
and their understanding and their
respect that they give towards
everyone uh it's been an amazing session
thank you representative nunes
representative salzburg
i think you already asked okay
representative
yuri
uh thank you mr chair just taking
advantage of uh wrapping things up last
night in hudson
they uh rededicated the palmer center a
cte center
uh that uh this committee in finance and
since uh uh marjorie's on right now
um did this has
right now doubled the number of regional
students to attend
that attended in 2019 uh
almost every graduate from alvern from
the cte center
has a job or is uh placed in the college
including some rather prestigious
colleges such as berkeley and
the accounting school down in waltham i
forget the name of it um
but it's it's really uh fine we did the
uh
session last night and i wanted to thank
everyone who was involved in that
in getting state matching funds for
that infrastructure development and
that's real infrastructure development
thank you
thank you representative any further
comments from committee members
saying none then we will see you
tomorrow at